I try to go to work for The New York
Times or The Washington Post because I
still think it first of all I mean the
website of the New York Times
particularly is one of the most amazing
sources of news and information I've
ever seen it's better than the paper if
you can drill deeper
I still love reading the paper I read
The Washington Post I read the New York
Times in their paper form a couple days
a week but I really look at it on on the
web and now you know those institutions
still do old-fashioned reporting and and
do it do it well so that would still be
my first my first choice I think the
main thing is to find something that
gives you joy doing it you know the most
fun years of my life perhaps in many
regards were aged 16 to 20 at the
Washington star learning and becoming a
reporter very young and learning this
this craft and being with these
wonderful people now and whether that
exists anymore I kind I don't think it
does I don't think there's the kind of
camaraderie that there once was but look
I think you can do great work for Vanity
Fair you can do great work for New York
magazine there are plenty of places to
do it and it can be exciting I think
it's very difficult for a young people a
young person to get the kind of notice
because there's so many people involved
in what's called journalism today and as
there are fewer and fewer major sources
of information that draw
disproportionate attention there's a
dilution and it's harder to get noticed
because readers go to more places
the it was easier I think for individual
journalists to get noticed 30 40 years
ago
well I think one thing is I I would say
be a good listener I think that most
journalists tend to be very bad
listeners particularly as as television
superseded so much in importance of of
what newspapers once had in terms of
prominence in the community which
occurred in the 70s and 80s 90s a lot of
reporters ran in with microphones and
stuck them in people's faces with the
object of sound bites really for the
purpose of manufacturing controversy the
real purpose of of a reporting of
journalism is to illuminate what is real
you know real existential truth what's
going on around us
that's not sensationalism that's not
manufactured controversy that's not it's
about context and listening you know
almost all the good stories that I have
ever done I've had a preconceived notion
of what the story might be and my
preconceived notion has always turned
out to be wrong from Watergate to
anything else that I've done it's fine
to have that preconceived notion to
maybe ask some questions but then give
people a chance to answer those
questions don't hammer them with your
preconceived notion and I think that
that's it so much of our journalism is
about that and reporters have become
lousy listeners to me you you sit there
and you wait long enough people want to
tell the truth actually if you give them
a chance and and to give you there's so
much in that gray matter things aren't
always black and white so I think being
a good listener is is something that and
I learned that very young I'm happy to
say because I love to find out what
people want to tell me let them dictate
the conversation not me then
I wrote you know I wanted to say at some
point look why did you put your hand in
a cookie jar
if that's what a relevant question is
get it in at some point but let's you
know maybe the hand was in the in the
cookie jar you know for four reasons I
never dreamed of I'd like to know those
reasons before I started acting we don't
were not prosecutors that's the other
thing in Watergate you know we were not
prosecutorial we went where the
information took us prosecutors had a
different function it looked like all
our reporting was going to go for not in
terms of having a road you know Nixon
was reelected by a huge margin after the
major stories we had written so if the
object it was at that point if our
object had been to be prosecutorial we
had failed but I wasn't our object our
object was the best obtainable version
of the truth I think that simple concept
is if the more you ponder the best
obtainable version of the truth the more
you become imaginative about about what
that means and how to go about it and
how to be fair and how to be judicious
not judicial another thing is have fun
at this you know that's the I think an
awful lot of that aspect has been lost
the fun this ought to be fun because
you're you're examining the human
condition that's fun the other thing
about the best obtainable version of the
truth is that it doesn't exaggerate one
aspect of our culture for instance the
sensational Fame you know most people
aren't famous and yet the you know
there's this great desire in our culture
for fame and which is an important thing
to write about and endl and to look at
but at the same time we need to look at
how most people live we need to look at
what's really going on
among human beings and and any
institutions in that they interact with